I'm just saying these guys have a coming
rule number one of Xavier school never
break into cables house I still want
that dude to be cable after you see this
movie you will - don't breathe the
premise is wonderfully simple these
three young folks they like breaking
into houses and stealing [ __ ] and it see
this easy mark it's easy right this is
old guy he's blind was gonna break into
his house and steal like $300,000 that
he must have in there easy simple right
wrong old yes blind yes but the dude is
played by Stephen Lang at any time
you're breaking into slangs house you
are [ __ ]
I didn't even call you old slang I'm
sorry please please don't kill me in my
sleep and after that enter the survival
horror most accurate Resident Evil movie
we have yet just so happens the house is
a lot smaller and there's just one dude
trying to kill you
there is a dog felt seriously this movie
does a lot right this is terror this is
don't breathe is the perfect time so
many times met Stephen Lang he's walking
around with his gun out and you just I
mean they're all just holding their
breath trying to sneak by him and you're
holding your breath too because you're
like breather he's gonna kill us and
it's great because the horror movies
probably they use ghosts and ghouls and
goblins and things like that to bring
the fear out because that's what people
think they need to do and sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't but in the
end it's just that intense feeling of
something gonna kill you in the dark
Stephen Lang of his movies the burger
he's a normal dude he's blind he
shouldn't be terrifying he is but the
simplicity of the premise of this movie
is exactly what makes this movie great
reckoning this dude's house they broke
into the wrong blind guy's house now
they're trying to escape where the movie
falters is when it tries to go against
that grain of simplicity there is an
element in this movie this movie just
throws it in the last act where it's
like oh it's been relatively simple now
who now there's this I don't want to
spoil it I don't want to give it away
but in the end it just it sticks out
like a sore thumb to me I've been having
a fine time just watching these people
trying to escape this blind [ __ ]
house or they're the [ __ ]
technically extended break into his
place they're all dicks but it throws
this extra thing in there that I don't
think it had to throw in there I feel
like I'm gonna be in the minority on
that one but I've just thought about it
a lot and that's just how I feel about
that Stephen Lang in this movie
perfectly plays what is seemingly this
frail old man and then this monster I
mean monster because I think it's
awesome that he barely has any dialogue
he has so few lines in there granted
verbal
she's just one of the many elements that
makes acting so I can't say this is an
easier role just because he doesn't
speak in fact I think it's harder when
an actor no longer has speech to convey
the terrifying nature of his presence
and Bing yet it takes some skill to be
terrifying this is what I'm telling you
that's why slang should be cable on the
premise of acting ability not you know
because he's scary here guys in the end
don't breathe was a refreshing take on
the whole home invasion premise scene
home invasion movies a hundred times
before usually it's someone breaking
into the victims house not people
breaking into what is seemingly the
victim and then the tables turning and
now the people who broke into the house
are now the victims an element in the
movie doesn't really flow with me and
gel with me as much as I might have
wanted it to but doesn't change the fact
that for about an hour and a half of
this movie it's like it's tension like a
guitar string being wound ready to snap
that's what I wanted in this movie
that's what I got I will say don't
breathe is worth watching and worth
buying on blu-ray it's like if stick in
daredevil just lost his [ __ ] and started
killing folks alright guys so don't
breathe have you seen it what did you
think about it what's the most intense
movie you have seen lately or ever
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more